hey Friends by request today I'm going
to share with you what I eat in a day
this is the way that I manage to eat
healthy and a simplified way so that the
healthy option requires minimal effort
this is not to say that my weight is
better and I'm no nutritionist but
hopefully sharing what I do is helpful
to
you generally I wake up between 5 and
6:00 a.m. for more productive days and
to allow myself some much needed quiet
time to myself before my kids wake up
this is definitely my meantime
but because waking up early is generally
not something I want to do I've paired
this habit with something that genuinely
brings me a lot of Joy if you've seen my
channel for a bit you'll know that this
for me is lattes matcha coffee chai
turmeric whatever just give me a latte
and I'm a happy camper so every morning
after drinking a glass of water I
prepare myself a latte on this day it's
my favorite Masala chai and powder
form I love this brand because it has no
sugar added which is perfect for me to
use with my monk fruit
sweetener this is a much healthier
alternative from sugar because it
doesn't Spike blood sugar and insulin
levels which you'd be surprised if you
do your research many of the zero
calorie sweeteners actually Spike
insulin levels monk fruit is pretty
fruity tasting to me so I pair it with
teas but for coffee my preference is
ayral my favorite milk for this drink is
extra creamy oat milk but I had a coupon
for some free almond milk so almond milk
it is after heating up some milk things
get a little bit weird I've swapped out
my daily collagen supplement for gelatin
I know you might be thinking this is
gross it's actually flavorless but it
does thicken my drinks if I let it cool
because well it's
gelatin so I add my frothed mixture of
yumminess and I sprinkle some cinnamon
for kicks and Giggles if I were making
matcha I would just use almond milk and
instead and obviously omit the
cinnamon because we have chickens our
breakfast Monday through Friday is
almost always eggs cooked in different
ways but I try to always add a veggie
somehow sometimes this means a spinach
omelette or scrambled eggs with whatever
veggie leftovers we have on this day I
had some green
beans I add some salt and my favorite
seasoning for this Mexican tahen it's a
chili lemon spice mix that's more tingy
than spicy but I removed the label
because well visual clutter you
guys will w i l l will after a bit of
homeschooling I like to take a break by
having my kids help prepare their own
snack so generally this is something
easy and quick to prepare such as
berries with a plant-based yogurt or my
youngest favorite spinach and banana
smoothies he loves it and you actually
can't taste the spinach if I want to
make a protein version my favorite
protein powder by far is Sun Warrior and
either vanilla or strawberry this is
what I used everyday while I was on
clean keto because it doesn't Spike
blood sugar levels it's low carb it's
plant-based and it doesn't taste chalky
like most protein powders do by the way
I'm not sponsored by any of the
companies that sell any of the products
that I mentioned today these are
products that I've purchased with my own
money that I've been using for a long
time if you are interested in trying any
of them out though I will leave a link
down in the description box so you can
check them out I have separate videos
where I talk about my experience with
the keto diet as well as what I ate and
I want to make it very clear that my
primary goal was not to lose weight I
think I was like 9 months to a year
postpartum when I tried it but what my
initial goal and the reason why I wanted
to do it is because I realized that I
had a lot of inflammation in my body and
I wanted to give my body a reset period
so I did it very very differently than
what you might typically see on social
media and that was because I had a lot
of eczema I was hyperthyroid I had joint
pain I just had a lot of things that
made me realize I needed a break and so
I did it very very very differently I
basically omitted dairies I ate lots and
lots of veggies and so there was a lot
of different things that I did that
really was with the primary goal of
giving my body a reset a refresh so that
I could remove that inflammation and
I'll spoiler for you I had amazing
results my Eczema cleared my skin was so
much softer I slept better I felt better
I had so much energy the joint pain was
gone ah yay and I also did actually lose
inches off of my waist I did have an
amazing experience I'll leave the two
videos linked Down Below in case you
want to check them out but I do also
make it want to make it very clear that
I'm not any medical professional to be
telling you what you should be doing as
far as your own diet this is just what
has worked for me so take it with a
grain of salt but hopefully they'll be
helpful for you generally in our home
you'll never really find candies cookies
or things like that like past but what
we do tend to have is these little
protein bars that my husband absolutely
loves they're NCO bars I don't know that
I can say they're necessarily healthy
but he really enjoys them and he works
out in construction and this is like his
treat I guess for him and then what I
have for the kiddos we have another
little bit that didn't fit on top here
it's some Cliff Bars and these is not
something that again I would say is
particularly healthy but if we're going
out I prefer to give them something like
this than buying them junk food or just
just buying them things out just because
we're out and about so it's more like a
like a treat on sometimes it's not a
daily thing but we have these so this
this would be our junk food stash I also
want to share this little sticky note
with you in the process of filming this
video I made a challenge that I would
not use my microwave for an entire month
so I placed this little sticky note here
as a reminder to me so if you want to
check out how my experience goes be sure
to subscribe so you won't miss out on
that this has actually been an
incredible challenge for me because I
felt like I couldn't go without a
microwave so that's precisely why I did
it and I'm very surprised with what I
have found as far as snacking in the
home I generally like for them to have
natural things so we always have a
basket of fruit here available but we
don't really have an area that's
designated for like junk food or cookies
or candies so if you come to our house
you'll rarely rarely find those things
this is actually our candy bin and
usually we'll have either Cranberries or
dark chocolate that we'll have after
dinner time right here to the left of it
is my supplements this is what I take on
a daily basis and I'm not a doctor I'm
not anyone to really recommend these to
you it's just that I've taken these for
a long time Mega food has been the brand
that I have used for vitamins for years
I love Mega food because of the way that
they're made they're non-GMO and I've
also researched through lots of
different vitamins and I love them
because of the percentages that they
have on their different vitamins that
they have so I've been a very happy
customer of Mega food for oh gosh at
least like 5 to 8 years now and then the
other vitamin that I have here is Garden
of life is also a brand that I really
trust I specifically started taking a
vitamin B after having had thyroid
issues especially being hyperthyroid it
was
miserable and then I found this
particular brand that has just the
percentages that I really liked I also
like that it has Biotin and it really
really really helped me increase my hair
growth this paired with either a
collagen or my gelatin has been like
gold for me when it comes to just
improving my hair my skin just overall
health in the past I have Tak and
collagen currently I'm using gelatin
I've kind of really made a deal with
myself that I'd try it for at least 6
months because I read a study that
showed significant Improvement in hair
growth within a year span I didn't
really want to do an entire year but
actually within just a few months of
taking this I noticed a huge difference
I have a ton of baby hairs so these are
basically the supplements I take on a
daily basis it's either gelatin or
collagen lately it's been gelatin a
multivitamin and my vitamin B complex
there supplements that I take that I
don't take all the time but some
sometimes is cod liver oil these are the
two brands that I have tried I I like
them both I wish I could find an organic
version because this one has like I
think it says organic lemon but I'm like
okay big deal that's not actually
organic the entire thing but I haven't
found one so if you got any suggestions
you let me know I know a lot of people
that swear by omegas uh but for me I
found that taking them in liquid form
has been a lot more helpful than pills
and then sometimes I also take a
probiotic currently I'm not taking a
probiotic one because I like to give my
body a rest so I'll take it for a few
months and then take a break just so
that my microbiome doesn't get used to
it but then also because they're kind of
Hefty in price but this is the one that
I use no surprise Mega food this is the
one that my kids are currently taking
again I'm not sponsored by them even
though I would totally take a
sponsorship because I did significant
research on different vitamins I love
that they're non GMO I love the way that
they formulate their probiotics
specifically though I researched many
many different probiotics because a lot
of them are sneaky they will sell you a
a very expensive bottle for strains that
aren't even helpful for your body and
these have a lot of really really good
strains so I really love this particular
probiotic our body is mostly bacteria so
it makes sense that a probiotic would be
helpful but a tip if you've never taken
a probiotic for is that they should be
stored in a refrigerator because they're
a living organism so it makes sense that
you'd want to preserve them and nobody
asked but I'm going to show you our
pantry this is basically where we store
all of our canned goods and all of our
processed foods and you can see that
it's not a whole lot of canned stuff
because we mainly like to eat things
that are fresh a lot of different
vegetables but I still also don't really
think that it's like horrible to never
eat these sorts of things and especially
now that I'm a homeschool mom I am
cooking all the time and I've also been
doing my 30-day challenge of not using a
microwave and I honestly think I'm going
to continue so on the weekends I have
been doing these little packaged
pancakes basically quick and easy
they're totally not healthy but whatever
screw it like we eat healthy during the
week so I think that uh once a week
letting it go it's totally fine but we
do a lot of different things like for
example if I were to make the kids pasta
I generally make them with something
like the chickpea pasta and then I make
my own sauce with cauliflower and I put
it in the Vitamix so I make it in a
healthier version one of the things that
I love to do is these shataki noodles so
if they are wanting something that does
have noodles in them it's something
that's not going to spike their blood
sugar levels it's a lot a lot healthier
not to mention they're already packaged
so that you don't really need to cook
them personally I found that it's a lot
easier to stick with healthy eating if
you basically focus on eating lots of
different fegg yeast then you don't end
up feeling like you're limiting yourself
like oh I can never have pancakes with
uh sugar or whatever that is or I can
never have pasta I mean it's fine if we
do those things I'm never really beating
myself up over those things anymore
because we eat healthy most of the time
so treats are okay and I do not feel
guilty eating pancakes on the weekends
since I showed you the other side of my
pantry I guess I'll show you this as
well but I also wanted to take the time
to tell you that I think it's so much
easier to eat well if you kind of take
an account what actually goes into your
home because if you have things that are
healthy that have nutrition then you
don't have to worry about having uh the
desire to heat a whole bunch of junk
because the junk that you do have is
very limited or it's really a more
healthier version so this kind of for me
eliminates that worry of having
willpower and having to just constantly
struggle because I have junk food in the
house because well I don't really have
it here so nothing to worry about for
today's lunch I'm having one of my
favorites chickpea salad typically I add
whatever veggies or toppings I have and
some pickled or fresh onions in the
summer I especially love to make it with
a sweet dressing and strawberries or add
some avocado with a creamy dressing my
dressing of choice today is lemon garlic
dressing yum I love chickpeas so I
generally batch cook them with my slow
cooker I cook on high for eight hours
with chopped carrots herbs from the
garden my favorites are thyme and
rosemary salt and my favorite vegetable
buan free of MSG but packed with flavor
better than
buan sometimes I have this by itself as
a soup use them in a stir fry instead of
rice or drain them and serve them cold
with pico Deo and lime it's like my
super easy version of
Ceviche generally I also freeze a
portion for lazy days my future me
me I often fast in the evenings or just
eat last night's leftovers but for the
sake of showing you dinner I'll show you
a typical dinner in my home I love
cooking veggies on a pan with salt and
herbs and I often cook different veggies
and serve them with a protein sometimes
it's last night's chickpeas but on this
day my husband was in the mood for
shrimp I seasoned the shrimp with tahen
because I could basically put that stuff
on everything loading my fridge with
veggies keeping my meals simple and
batch prepping Basics helps me to eat
much healthier with very minimal effort
I hope you enjoyed this video and found
it helpful if you did like this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and
subscribe so you won't miss when I post
a new video and feel free to let me know
what other videos you'd love to see for
me in the future until next time bye for
now